look at this guy's going to come at you
with the cutter i mean it's going to be
the cutter the cutter and the cutter
it's an unbelievable pitch
burns ready deals again swang in a miss
fell behind an ortega and then dropped a
slider down low and inside and struck
him out
swings and misses on the cutter from
burns strikeout number two against
batter number two
a curveball wipes out ian half
and he gets the strikeout that pitch was
actually in the dirt but he strikes out
the side yeah justin steele has been
pretty decent this year he's the type of
guy he's got a very live arm matters
christian yelich 2018 mvp with
swinging a miss by yelich
justin steele with back-to-back
strikeouts after the air
as wilson contreras leads off the second
swinging a drive into right center this
is trouble warning track at the wall
leaping and caught by kane
oh
what a grab by lorenzo kane a leaping
catch up against the wall
he took a home run away from conference
with a catch on top of the wall that
would have hit
annie pina will lead off the bottom of
the second
media drills one to right center
ortega back it's gone
home run matty pina
to the opposite field he torments the
cubs again does a nice job of going with
this pitch sing just kind of running
away from him a little bit you see makes
contact back in the zone
reyes hits it hard tyving stopped by
patrick wisdom seen two great defensive
plays tonight wisdom gets a nice jump on
this thing fully extends
now they've loaded them up for wilson
contreras
bouncing ball diving stopper porrius
they get one out
run scores as steel comes home luisa
saved at least one more run from scoring
and it gets the second out of the inning
wilson contreras should be two for two
now he's over two
to be joined by the charismatic
shortstop william thomas
escobar hits one deep in the air to left
and gone
home run for escobar
and the brewers have the lead back it's
two to one what'd you think of that
willie
he practiced it on bp today that was
amazing let's hear that again how did it
go
now
yeah
lorenzo kane had that great catch
earlier against wilson contreras kind of
fell hard on the ground after and he's
come out of the game jackie bradley jr
is in center field see lorenzo kane on
the milwaukee bench
you know he goes into the wall but i
don't think that's where he hurt himself
i mean yeah that's some impact but watch
when he hits the ground
i mean that's not oh man
it's almost like a you know whiplash or
a real job to the ribs
i mean here we go and let's go to some
concrete oh
lines of base hit to right
frank the tank
for the two out single here in the fifth
if you're a right-handed hitter you've
got to look it's going to be pitch away
hopefully get it up in the zone and
look at just just take your base hit
take it
gonna come uniform just outstanding ian
happ swings and hits one in the air deep
right center field way back gone
cubs take the lead
a two-run home run by ian happ
gets his pitch not much movement on it
up in the zone and just absolutely
hammers it look at we've been saying it
all night long where in the count is
burns most vulnerable
it's in that 0 count
[Applause]
and he's just absolutely tormented the
cubs this year
i don't say and do we want to do this or
not swing on the base hit to center
yell it's around third
here he comes the throw is going to be
cut off
and we are back to even tied at three
luis aureus
with a solid base hit to center
yelich after the one-hour double scores
for urias rbi number 69 on the year now
the game there even though this has not
been burns best night you still want the
ace
he strikes out against burns
that should be the end of the night for
corbin burns
cubs touched him up a little but burns
strikes out 11.
as jace peterson leads off the bottom of
the sixth
and he drills one to deep right field
way back and gone
chase peterson has put milwaukee back on
top
i mean that thing just up in the zone he
keeps it elevated puts it into the
second deck absolutely crushes this
thing
kind of the job exercises contreras
drives one in the air deep left field
it's got a chance it's gone
high ball game long home run wilson
contreras box burger leaves this ball
right in the middle of the plate and i
mean contreras hammers this ball home
run number 20 for wilson and the game is
tied this one way over everything in
left center field
446 feet one of his longest ones
and apena leads off the eighth
he has done a nice job as the backup
catcher now he drills one down the left
field line toward the corner it's gone
manny pinagan
his second home run of the night it's
his third multi-home run game this year
and the brewers are three outs away from
clinching a playoff spot watch this
watch when he turns to the brewer dugout
that is great
that's off the glove of schwendell reyes
rounds third he's going to try to score
and contreras missed him
reyes gets by the tag
brewer team is still competing playing
like this thing is you know means
everything and you know they're going to
the playoffs yet here they are they're
already a run ahead ray is selling out
josh hayder as we talked a moment ago is
in there now to try and nail this one
down
three and two
in there strike three call
contreras in the face of the hope led up
by her chad whitson he's been ejected
and the cubs now have the tying runs in
scoring position
for a fourth straight year
the brewers are play off bound
strikes out wisdom
and milwaukee is back in the postseason